[inaudible]. Yeah, we can do it little.
Yes, exactly.
So a couple of days ago we did this thing,
we got Robert into the studio and I noticed that there's just friend [inaudible]
and we ambushed him and would be
the whole staff rushed in singing cake the whole deal.
[inaudible]
no, Robert famously hates his birthday.
It's been such a long time trying to hide my birthday, everybody in that.
But you can't really hide your birthday these days.
And I have had the extremely good fortune to work with this man for over 10
years.
So if you'll excuse us justice once we want to take this podcast to celebrate Mr
Robert Krulwich, we're Robert.
Well we didn't just bring you in here for cake and to listen to things,
to act in a real what you're sort of thinking, but we would love to,
to share some of your earlier work as the next podcast.
No talk about it. That's our executive producer, Ellen Horan.
She dug up a bunch of its old work from the archives and he eventually agreed to
let us play some.
And it's really interesting to hear this stuff because I'm not sure a lot of
people who listen to radio lab really get how much Robert Sensibility drives the
show.
Like his combination of theater and play and his desire to sound different than
other stuff on the radio and to ignore the rules, but in always,
always in service of a genuine attempt to understand or explain something.
And also it's just amazing how many creative lives he lived before he came to
radio lab. Right? Like here's one,
here's a piece from 1979 which is just a few years after NPR began.
I'm banks these days you have noticed they're trying out new systems.
More and more we're being asked to deal with machines instead of tellers.
And that's the way the banks want it. According to our business correspondent,
Robert Krulwich
right here in Washington, a few doors away from national public radio. There's,
yeah, listen to your offers.
You a chance at a colored television set and they have a treasure chest with 10
Susan B. Anthony Dollars inside,
which could be yours if you are willing to stand there with three minute
demonstration of their new automatic teller system.
I don't know,
let's just try to have a period I went to stay strongly nasal cause I thought
nasal is powerful. I think if you have a nose you should use it
in the pieces.
A actually about how p banks are starting these crazy things called htms and
people are a little freaked out.
I've had some interesting problems with these machines. Uh,
they have eaten my card from time to time. Do you mean they, they,
they mutilated and at one point, uh,
Robert in euro to explain why the banks were lobbying so hard for these ATS,
he almost bursts into song.
Okay, great. Good. You send the check to Sears,
Sears deposit the check in its bank. The bank sends a check to a regional bank.
From there it goes to your regional bank is in your very own area.
They mail it back to your hometown bank,
which meals it back to you in a statement you get at the end of the month.
The check shows up in the packet, hopefully.
Now remember you listened to the whole thing through that is four different
mailings for just one check.
With all that postage now wouldn't it be the banks argue to stop mailing the
check from place to place place and try another system.
That system is called electronic fund transfer and already to cut down on
postage and on handling is more painful for me.
Here's another one we listened to.
It's also from 1979 this one is a report about,
well a report in quotes about interest rates.
There is intense pressure from two different groups for changes in interest
rates. One group wants them down, the other group wants them up even higher.
Both sides are powerful and important to our economy and the INS and outs of
their struggles are worthy of an opera. In fact, they are an opera
[inaudible].
And now from the Palazzos validate,
we present this live performance of Alfredo.
Tucci is a mortal opera rato interest. So, and here is our host,
Seward chaplain.
Thank you very much.
There aren't very many operas that deal exclusively with the subject of interest
rates, but this one I think is the most magnificent of all to cheer routed,
widowed in a single afternoon after a traumatic event that according to his
biographers Tanish Lao briefed scarred him for life.
Breech says the two Chu was walking along the road in the city when passing by
in Tram.
He saw the exquisitely beautiful Sylvia fire and as she rode by he knew that he
wanted desperately to meet her. Although he was a poor composer,
he decided that he would send her a gift,
it would impress her and he chose wall to wall carpeting.
In order to get the money for the carpet,
though he had to get a household finance loan to his hotter,
he found out what the interest rates were.
I'm alone and as he writes in his Aria [inaudible], they were prohibitive.
Our first act today closely follows these real life events.
And as the act urbans where in the Italian Section of Louisville, Kentucky,
where Angelina will,
she wants a wall to wall carpet limbs at the interest rate is 18 and a half
percent.
The scene begins if she gasps in astonishment and resolves not to buy the
carpet. Non Carpaccio Blah. She and her friends, Nina,
tell this to the carpet seller.
Petty Gino Pedagogy no is greatly disturbed and says your value per say,
the businessman's demand is what he sings. I see.
We're now ready for the act begin as Angelina learns that she cannot afford her
car.
[inaudible]
no,
now they go to Penn Chino. He's not happy.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so here's the thing about this.
A Paul Volcker at the time was the chairman of the Federal Reserve.
And what I do in act three is I take, uh,
Paul and I from a press conference that he was here, which I was at,
and I cut him
into the opera,
ladies and gentlemen, where face to face
woo with economic difficulties, really unique in our experience.
The question of whether we should be putting another screw to interest rates is
it's just one of those walking on a razor heads right now.
[inaudible] Alfredo,
two chairs offset by this, the congress getting a standing ovation.
It's the car followed by Mr [inaudible].
I can't believe that that was on national public radio. That was the crazy days.
Yeah, we could. We did things then like I, I, I interviewed an anchovy.
They aired all that kind of stuff. So there was no one,
there was no gatekeepers who were like, no, no. After the upper,
we listened to a,
something from 1992 which would be just after I graduated high school and here
Robert Teamed up with a couple of actors and Comedians to do a sort of a yearly
recap.
The thing.
I'm Robert Krulwich and welcome to the second annual edition of Backfire.
This program has been a tradition on NPR since 1991 and this is the occasion
when we gather to review the events of the year in this case,
the year 1992 and once again, we were able to round up our regular observers.
Buck. Henry is a screenwriter and a pundit. You go to movies. The graduate,
by the way,
Jane curtain is an actress and a funded original cast Saturday night live.
Tony Hendra,
a pundit famous satirist and a pundit and all three of you now at double a
double punted in Tony's case. Let's have the first question and it's from me.
Robert Krulwich pundits.
What was the real explanation for President Bushes collapse?
This is now all the way back. A year ago at the state dinner at Tokyo.
You recall the event book? I do. Indeed. He collapsed
Stan. More importantly, he vomited on the, was it the prime minister,
the foreign minister and the prime minister, his lap, but Bush, as you know,
is anonymous name. Anyway,
Bush is the sound that you make when you throw up,
so we could have simply been responding to someone saying, by the way,
what is your name? And the Sushi came with it.
It is also as I have read my history,
accustom of world leaders from time to time to throw up on the lap of the
minister of a friendly government.
It demonstrates confidence in your host,
a sense of the excellent of the dinner being served and a tradition of
giving back something you've been given,
pushed down a continent politician of giving his all.
How then do you account for the surprised expression and, and,
and the lack of delight really on the face of the prime minister when receiving
this gift? Uh, from President Bush.
I think it was because it was done after the first course as opposed to after
the conclusion that in India,
you simply throw your dinner in the face of your host before. And just to get,
I'd like to point out by the way, there is some misconception here,
which is that this was a single event. It's actually a, uh,
apparently this habit of throwing up in the nearest stranger's lap is,
it was not just a question of courtesy.
It's something that a bush has done ever since he was a little boy. And in fact,
it's the origin of his, uh, of his nickname poppy. Ah,
because his mother mumsy used to refer to is in veteran habit of up chucking as
the pumping is original family nickname was projectile poppy.
Yeah, he, this would go on.
We would do this like for for two hours and Manoli who was our, our our,
she would not even smile
where we were like this was the least listen to a program and all of NPR,
they reduced us from 12 a year.
So two a year to one only on New Year's Eve at 10:00 PM do you know what it's
like to be scheduled for 10:00 PM on New Year's Eve? That means you have failed,
but then this is how life works.
I'm sitting in my house and the phone rings and it's the White House and some
guy says, do you,
is your group available on like next March the third? I mean,
we want him in the East Room. I said of the White House. He goes, yeah. I said,
well I don't think you do. I said,
maybe you should just ask whoever's idea this was to like vetted or something.
So I about two weeks pass and then the funding, he said,
well it's good news and Penn, I listened to it and yes it isn't funny,
but the people who think it's funny is a person and this the president of
states. So that's the the end. And so we went,
we went to the east room and it was incredible. Really.
My wife was there and you look across at your wife and you're at the White
House, the president of laughing at these dumb jokes.
There's certain moments where you feel strangely blessed. You know, like,
like either you are really great giraffe in some previous life and this is your
reward or every so often God just leans down through the clouds and kisses you
and says like,
this will be just a chance for you to be in joy.
And so that night I just, that that, you know, Gosh they were,
it was a big deal. There's a couple pieces that you've pre
Radiolab where a, like as a,
as a young radio reporter, you know how you were in your nose phase,
you heard your nose face. Okay. I think we,
we all sort of start in some idea of what we should sound like,
what we should do, what's, what's permissible.
And then you hear this thing come out of the radio, uh, and you're like,
I didn't know you could do that. I just didn't know you that was allowed. Yeah.
I wanna play a one piece of yours that had that effect on me. Uh,
think you did this in 1981 or something. I heard it, you know,
years later when it was featured on this website. But, uh,
and this is pre radio lab. So I heard this. We hadn't met yet. This is, well,
it's just play it.
The story of Lacrosse a lot is one of the great commercial rivalries in New York
history began when Sam Lawsky opened a moving company years and years and years
ago. Way Back, way back. I can understand even before my time,
and I've been with the firm 22 years.
Peter precocial runs the office at the Cresa Lawsky trucking company in
Brooklyn.
Why am I hitting? That was a big family, brothers,
uncles and cousins and they were all
very competitive. You know, competitive is putting it mildly.
The firms started in 1904 when Sam crowds the Lawsky and his brother Dave crabs.
The Lawsky formed a hauling company called Sam crabs, Lawsky and bro.
The Bro was for brother and they would move heavy things like church bells and
statues and to help them. They hired their nephew,
Mike Grads Lawsky for 20 years. Everything was fine with the Sam,
Dave and Mike until uncle Dave decided to bring his sons into the business.
Under the circumstances,
Mike had to disassociate himself from the uncles and start on his own.
That is Mike's brother who will serve as our narrator in this story.
Now it is the late 1930s there are now two Cresa Lawsky moving companies.
Mike's and his uncles is to remind customers that he was now in business for
himself.
Mike took out a series of display ads in the New York telephone book on the very
page where the crowds will, La skis are listed on the ad, said, remember Mike,
there was only one Cresa Lawsky. In addition, his brother says he put,
remember Mike on all the trucks, but it didn't work.
Too many customers could not remember which cries Lawsky was,
which they just opened the phone book and call any crazy Polaski and that is
when Mike got this incredible idea.
He'd taken it if he could move ahead of his uncle's in the telephone book,
people would see his name first and then they'd call him first instead of the
other crazy Laski. So he decided to add a new listing in the telephone book.
He took out the V in Cresa,
loved ski and put in a you that made it Cresa Laos Ski,
K. R. A. S. I. L. O. U. Now that moved him one entry ahead of his uncle.
Students by the alphabet use always proceeded, Viz,
but Mike Kras allow ski as he was now called,
was not prepared for the profitability of his cousin Milton Kozlowski.
Milton. Milton Kras Lawsky was another young son, son of David [inaudible].
In the early 1940s Milton started a new trucking company called Cresa Lao ski
with a UW, as was the case with Mike, but to move ahead of Mike,
he changed his first name from Milton to Mick,
m I C K Crass Lawsky with a you hoping that he would be ahead of Mike in the
listing, which of course he was the uncle's. Meanwhile,
anxious to catch up join forces with Milton or Mick and created the Kratza Laski
safe company.
They dropped the V and has a Lawsky put in an oh so the uncle's Craz,
a Laski moved ahead of Mike's Krebs allow ski.
Mike was a quite upset as well.
He might've been for revenge.
He countered with a Greek leap taking over the Atlas Safety Company,
which moved him to the front of the telephone book,
leaving the case behind to the finer air of the a section,
but one year later the uncles who were on the same page, the act,
the safe company was a division of s crass Lawsky and brothers.
According to Mike's brother.
By the mid 1950s even though Mike still had only one moving business in Brooklyn
and Metropolitan Avenue,
Mike Cresa Laski by this time had 18 listings under 18 different names in the
telephone book. All the uncles had 13 listing. Yes,
we had listings throughout the yellow pages and white pages for one company so
that we could get all the listings ahead of the other relatives.
Could you do it for fun or no? This was not for fun.
This was very serious.
There was no reason we felt that another member of the family that has just
walked in should capitalize on the name of Christ. Sloppy.
No final salvo was fired by the uncles. Actually,
it was a cousin on the uncle side named Marvin.
He created the a acme [inaudible] safe company.
After that,
the public was so completely confused that according to Richard Kozlowski,
all the crabs, the Lawsky businesses began losing customers.
It does affect the business when people say who,
who are you and who do you belong to?
Mike died in the 1960s his wife sold the business and changed her name from
Cresa. Lawsky to crass and then moved to Florida.
My ex brother Monro stayed in the business. He now calls his friend,
whoever the empire safe company, he and his son,
Richard would like to use the name Creswell. Lawsky. It is after all their name,
but they don't dare because there was now a whole new generation of [inaudible]
moving into the phone book.
The original [inaudible] company has now been split,
so they are all over the lot.
There are now more sons and there are more names here with my colleague Margot
Adler.
We're going to read you the latest set of listings from the current New York
telephone book and the New York yellow pages. Michael
a a acne Cresa Lawsky Cresa Lawsky division of Acme safe present,
low ski Mike Trucking and New Right company guys. Lawsky brothers,
Mike and Monroe Empire Cresa love ski seat companies, blocky brothers.
Safe Company, division of Safe Smith's Inc Cresa love ski division of accuracy.
Mike Cresa Lawsky saves Monro Crescent Lawsky safe. Reza La Safe Company,
Inc Pres a love ski safe collection. Acme Safe Company Credit Laski division.
Not connected with any other Cresa. Lawsky
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we'll be back in a moment.
Hi, this is Sharon Ellaria and I'm calling from Piscataway New Jersey.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thanks.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
You vote with your dollars when you shop. Well,
what if you could do the same when you invest with swell,
invest in high growth companies without checking your values at the door.
It's a market opportunity linked to global progress in clean water when you will
bill energy medical breakthroughs. Get a $50 bonus when you open your
account@swellinvesting.com slash Radiolab
jet here.
So after Ellen Horn and I and the whole staff ambushed Robert in the studio and
played up stories towards the end of the whole thing.
Robert went off on this insane digression and this happens all the time in the
studio.
Like he'll go off on something and unfortunately cut it out because it's not
part of the story we're telling. But in this case, we're going to put it in,
in honor of his birthday. And also because it just,
it just illustrates what an insanely curious duty is. Like.
He has this incredible curiosity that makes him like a heat seeking missile for
Weirdo adventures.
And that is what has attracted me to him and the entire staff to him.
And probably a lot of the people who listened to him.
So here's just a random digression of his, uh,
it's him telling the story of his first television piece for ABC News.
One of the great things, I'm sitting on an airplane and the man next to me,
you know, you just asked like, what do you do? He says, Oh,
I'm in golf ball retrievable. [inaudible] I say, what is that?
I'm in golf ball retreat. Like in golf courses. Yeah. You know,
we gather golf balls, that's a thing people make lots of money.
How much money do you make money while we make we make you know,
a dime for every ball that we recover, mn,
we pay that and we can sell it in Japan for quarter. I say, what's your problem?
He said, well, the problem we have really the only really one is is uh,
is gators. I said, what do you mean gators? Well, they, they,
they live in the waterholes and the kids who who do this work are teenagers.
I said, well, do you mean you hire teenagers?
And then there's like wild animals that could eat them as well.
Obviously we have to remove the gators. I was thinking,
where's the golf ball retrieval? What an interesting story.
That'd be a great story. Then. Then he suddenly talking about gator removals,
gator removal. That'll be great stories as well. Well, we use,
we use a guy named Mr. Campbell. He's out in Florida.
I mean there's a guy who's specialize. Yeah, he's he, he works Florida, Texas,
southern California. I said, well, I've got to go meet Mr. Campbell,
so I call Mr. Campbell.
The phone is answered by some person who's not Mr. Campbell.
It's his very angry wife.
He at age 80 has skipped that with some floozy and she is like pissed at him.
So she says, well, if you're calling, he's not here. He's out with her.
I said, oh, I am sorry.
I didn't know because I was thinking maybe he'd be a subject of an interview.
I would talk about, you know,
alligator retrieval and well did he ever mentioned the gross point zoo,
so being no fool.
I said occasionally and it turned out that when they had lived in Gross Pointe
Michigan, a very fancy suburb,
they hadn't created the law that he had collected the largest collection of
gators in, in North America, in his basement,
in a series of tubs that he had built and irrigated and every kid in the
neighborhood whose parents were all at general motors or something,
all knew about this secret thing. The police didn't, the adults didn't,
but the kids did.
And she said in the course of this conversation until the sowing incident,
what I said, what now you can imagine the fever.
I have gone from golf ball retrieval to alligator removal to now secret zoo in
basement of fancy suburb. And suddenly there's now the sewing machine incident.
It turns out there was a sewing circle at this house that Mrs. Campbell,
the aggrievance, Mrs. Gamble Ran.
And in this sewing circle they would bring singer sewing machines and one lady
turn on her singer sewing machine and its vibration caused the alligator in the
basement. All of the alligators in the basement
[inaudible]
it sounded like a jungle riot from the basement.
But you're saying they were upstairs sewing and below them, these alligators,
the alligators, half of them male go
[inaudible]
when this lady turns on her.
So George Campbell figures out that it was a B flat.
So it was his theory that it was a B flat bed caused the balance.
Was that like the sound they make when they mate or when they fight or when
nobody knew a,
if it were true and no one knew why it would be true if it were true.
So I tell this poor girl Barbara [inaudible] from, from [inaudible].
ABC was your producer? Yes. She's like 23 or something.
So you know we're going to do, we're going to hire a marching band,
the high school marching band in full plumage and we are going to go to Florida
to a place that is packed with alligators, a wildlife reserve,
and I'm going to have these plumes high school people play be flat too,
and there's going to be everywhere.
So I get the high school band, they get on a bus, I get the ABC crew,
I get the very nervous Barbara Fatina who doesn't know what I'm doing and we
all, we all go out to the Audubon place.
We arrive and there's this mass of grass and you could see alligators
everywhere. The band gets up.
This is from the TV piece still.
The porter from the Cypress Lake high school marching band will now play a B
flat on the French horn.
We have no response.
Mr Porto will now play a B Plat on the Tuba.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and there's not a sound, not a rustle, not interest.
I'm looking at all these alligators. They don't win. They don't blink,
they don't move. They don't care. And Barbara F is looking at me like,
what am I going to do at that moment? A bus pulls in,
filled with French tourists who get out to go look at alligators.
They come down the thing and they see all these gaily dressed Americans in olive
green and large plumes coming out of their head,
which they're not apparently a French.
This is already a Fellini film that you're describing. And so they say, I,
they say what's wrong? And now at this point I'm a little bit sad and,
and you know, and the son I've, I,
this prince about three 30 going on four o'clock and it's the winter time.
So we only have til about six before they have sunshine. And I say to them,
this is the situation. So they, they let this guy from the France says, Oh,
you see this is the problem in Michigan, they had, um,
they was in dub in tubs, right? It was in dubs, in Boston, in [inaudible].
So the sound game at from the sewing machine down flew into the
[inaudible] grass and water and mud is a different thing.
You need to go to one of those parks.
[inaudible] well,
they put old alligators in concrete [inaudible] like it's like the tubs.
So I said, okay, that's the thing to do. So now the people from France,
they get in there bus, the bus, the musicians, they get in the bus, their bus,
George, his wife,
they're hanging on and the ABC crew and Barbara Feeding in the bus and we all
drive to, I want to, it's on, it's in the piece. Lester pipers,
everglades wonder gardens on old route 41 now where you arrive and there's,
there are, there are 50 alligators in poured concrete sitting in islands.
My camera crew is so certain that nothing is going to happen,
that they get into the pit standing on these concrete islands,
not inches from these alligators.
And the sun is now kissing the tops of the trees.
So Fidelis says, Robert, we have one shot. I mean,
do something. I can't go back to New York with nothing.
I have nothing. And the friends one, you just need to do,
put it in the concrete. You may be fine. You saw the fringe.
Everybody's there. Yes. And then so then we, um,
we're standing there and uh,
one more time. First the French horn.
Uh,
okay. The Tuba
[inaudible] there's a kind of quiet
and then there's a kind of a bubble knowing the first thing that an alligator
does when it's about to Bello is it shakes its rib cage.
So all of a sudden it's like the whole pool of water turned to ginger Ale.
It's this plus a plus e plus e and then all the males were just half of the male
PT animals in this thing. All of them all at once. Make that
[inaudible].
This is the sound that Mrs. Campbell sewing circle heard coming up through the
basement.
[inaudible]
they start to pray. She's from North Africa. I don't know what she's doing.
Did the French people [inaudible] told de George
and when that piece aired,
it was my first taste because it was so our people, you know,
like you get a base, you get an audience, uh,
like say four and a half million or something in a primetime show and then you
get all the people who are clicking through, right?
So those are called the butterflies. So I was given,
I still have the chart of what happened that night on television.
Like people were looking and clicking,
and then they see this man with the pole with the Tuba and the alligators in the
corner and the French guys and the audience goes, but you couldn't put,
you couldn't, but you can. I'm hearing like 3 million people every minute.
That time I had such a high, whatever. That score is like unbelievable.
I'm joining.
The next week I did something on the Internet and porn and it went actually the
actually opposite direction, which was a whole nother story.
But for that week I was like, you are king. I was king
and he still is.
[inaudible] was this, it wasn't an unpleasant experience before,
you know, talking about myself. Is it something I don't mind doing ever?
You just fell into it. Yeah. Thanks for listening. I'm by myself.